MICHAL SEGALOV: Welcome to the
first episode of Women
Techmakers in Israel.
Women Techmakers started in
the United States, and its
goal is to increase visibility
of highly successful women
entrepreneurs in the tech
industry, and it's now rolling
out globally.
We have with us Rony
Ross today,
which we will indroduce.
We will quickly introduce
ourselves and then move on.
I am Michal Segalov, I'm a
software engineer at Google's
Israel R&D Center.
Here I work on technical
infrastructure, mainly on the
Google computer network.
Prior to that, I worked on
YouTube and prior to that, I
worked in Search Quality.
I hold a computer science
[INAUDIBLE] from the Technion
and a masters from Tel
Aviv University.
And here with us is Daniela
Raijman-Aharonov.
DANIELA RAIJMAN-AHARONOV: Hi!
I'm Daniela Raijman-Aharonov.
I'm an engineering manager and
software engineer in Google's
R&D Center in Israel,
like Michal.
I've been here for a little over
five and a half years,
and my current group is
technical infrastructure, just
like Michal.
We go back a long time.
So my teams work on products
whose goal is to optimize the
way that other Google products
use the Google network.
I have a bachelor's degree and
a master's degree in computer
science from Tel Aviv
University, and I live in the
suburbs of Tel Aviv with my
husband and son, and we're
expecting another one.
So I'm very proud to introduce
our first guest to
Israel, Rony Ross.
Rony is the chairman and founder
of Panorama Software.
And Rony will start by telling
us a little bit
about Panorama Software.
RONY ROSS: OK, so Panorama
Software is a business
intelligence company.
It's been around for a while,
actually since 1994.
But what is special about
Panorama Software is that
right now as a company, we are
actually redefining business
intelligence into the new world
of social, contextual,
and suggestive systems.
But first of all, let me tell
you a little bit about myself.
I've been in computer science
most of my life.
I have a master's degree from
the Weizmann Institute of
Science and an MBA from Tel
Aviv University, and I was
actually privileged to work
in one of Israel's first
high-tech companies, called
Scitex at the early
stages of my career.
And eventually I opened up
Panorama Software, as a
business intelligence company
in 1994, and I'll tell the
story maybe a little
bit later.
So, about Panorama today.
We have been in business
intelligence for a long time.
We have thousands of customers
using our product.
And about three and a half years
ago, we looked around us
and we saw how the world--
the way people used technology
is changing.
People in the consumer world,
and the personal world use
technology in a different way.
They collaborate a
lot with others.
They are all in the social
environments of sorts, you
know, like Facebook,
Google, et cetera.
They all get systems who know
who they are, and know to
suggest to them what
they may like.
You know, like YouTube
suggesting to you what
additional videos you may want
to watch, or Amazon suggesting
to you books that you've read
based on the books that you've
read before and what your peers
and friends have been
reading with similar tastes.
And we looked at that and we
said, well, you know, it's
time that the enterprise
systems, we also take this
angle-- we've also opened up
and changed the way of
operation to be more
crowd-sourcing, more open more
suggestive, more
recommendation.
But you know, most of
the ERP systems are
very rigid and very--
there's nothing much about
crowd-sourcing when you want
to issue an invoice, right?
You either issue an invoice
properly or you don't.
But when it comes to
decision-making in the
organization, this is where
we thought we could bring
enormous value to the
organization.
In enabling people to
collaborate better with their
peers and get the system to help
them in analyzing what
they need to analyze, and
suggesting to them better ways
of analyzing and suggesting
to them better solutions.
So we actually redesigned,
from the ground up, our
original system, so that
it now is social.
In what respect it is social?
It really recognizes the other
people in the organization.
It knows what their interests of
each person are, either by
these people defining what they
want through tags, or by
looking at the things that
indicate that they like, or
tracing the way that they
analyze and what they view out
of there-- the I system-- the
things that the I system in
the organization offers them to
look at, what they do, and
the system knows to connect
between me, as the decision
maker and the other people
in the organization.
And I think you're going
to have that first
demonstration, right?
So now we have a system
that knows--
that enables people to
collaborate on the data.
Why is this important?
Because there are many systems
who enable collaboration.
But enabling collaboration,
just talking, and just
exchanging--
if used, it's not enough.
What is special about the
enablement of collaboration of
the data, is that it makes
collaboration meaningful, and
it makes collaboration useful.
Part of the problems that the
organizations have today that
say yes, we can use Yammer, we
can use Jive, but we don't
know what we are getting.
But it's very obvious what you
can get from BI if you enable
collaboration.
You actually get a shorter
resolution time of issues.
The time that it takes between
identifying your problem and
the time it takes to resolve
it gets shorter.
And this shortening of the
decision window is very, very
important to the organization.
And the next feature that we
introduced to the system,
which we thought was extremely
important, is the contextual
and suggestive feature.
This is that feature about
understanding who you are,
what your needs are, comparing
you to other people in the
organization and based on that,
making suggestions to
you on what you may want.
The system may either suggest
to you who you want to
collaborate with, it can suggest
to you additional
views, it can suggest
to you solutions.
This is a contextual and
suggestive system.
So here is where we're going
to have the second piece.
OK?
So and on top of all of that, we
also have the new algorithm
sorry, based on the way that
people have been analyzing
data, now simulate the way
people have been doing
analysis, and provide the best
result, as people would have
otherwise found, only they
would've toiled a lot in order
to get to this result.
And this is where we're going
to have the third system.
OK?
Now, what I would like
is to wrap it all up.
So what we actually saw-- we saw
how we took a regular BI
system and we opened it up to
be social, to be contextual,
to be suggestive--
we opened it up so that it
really covers the next step in
the decision making of the
organization, which is the
step of here's where we work as
a team and make decisions.
Now we figured that BI would be
the perfect place to start
with this initiative, because
BI is the hub of the
organization decision making.
Well-run organizations have all
their issues displayed in
the BI system, which is the
system that actually displays
data for managers to
make decisions on.
So if you address and make the
decision making social, you
get enormous value.
So you get shorter decision
windows, you get higher
quality decisions, you've got
better adoption of the system,
because you've got better ways
to utilize the system.
I, personally, before I used a
system like Necto, I would
spend hours trying to find out
what additional views or
reports or KPIs would be useful
to me in my work.
Today I don't need to.
The system suggests to me what I
would probably prefer, based
on the way that I'm using the
system, people like me with a
similar interest.
So it increases the penetration,
it increases the
proficiency of the users, and
altogether it brings an
enormous value.
DANIELA RAIJMAN-AHARONOV: So
it seems from what you're
saying that actually within
Panorama you would use your
own software as well for
business intelligence.
RONY ROSS: Of course.
How could we know what works and
what doesn't if we didn't
use it ourselves.
And you know what?
It wasn't easy.
It wasn't easy to get
to that, but we did.
It's very important.
DANIELA RAIJMAN-AHARONOV: It's
a very interesting approach,
which we also use at Google.
So I'm wondering, from using it
internally have you learned
something that you thought
things were going to work
right in a specific way, and
then when you started using
it, you said, oh no, this has
to be completely different?
RONY ROSS: Yes, we did.
We found a lot of ways which
we found out that we really
should be doing-- that
there was a better
way of doing things.
It doesn't mean that the
old way didn't work.
It just means that there is a
new way to do things, and it
opened up my eyes to see where
the focus of other people was,
especially looking at me, kind
of in a higher position.
Looking to see where the focus
of the organization keeps
shifting and how people advance
into analyzing issues
because certain periods
of time you analyze
profitability, and then you
analyze sales, and then you
analyze investments, and then
you analyze percentage of
resources invested
in certain areas.
And you can see how the focus
of the organization changes
and it's very easy to keep
up and be with how people
do what they do.
DANIELA RAIJMAN-AHARONOV:
That's cool.
Do you also work with
your users to get
feedback from them?
RONY ROSS: From the start.
This is actually
how we started.
Let me tell you a small story
about how we started.
As I said, I have a masters in
computer science and an MBA,
and the one thing that I always
wanted was to harness
IT to bring strategic value
to the organization.
Strategic as opposed
to functional or
performance-wise, because IT
was always about enabling
performance in the organization
and about the
tactics, but I was looking into
how I can really make a
change in the paradigm
of the organization.
Make it more competitive.
Bring out this competitive edge
that is so important to
each and every organization.
And, you know, I got
there by mistake.
We were doing--
I set up my own consultancy
company in late 1990s.
We were doing consultancy
work.
This was early Windows days.
And what we did, it sounds
amazing today, but we took
systems that were in Unix and
we rewrote them for our
customers in Windows
technology.
So in order to convince a
customer to do a job, we
developed a small reporting
module that showed reports
online in a Windows environment
for that customer.
And we looked at [INAUDIBLE],
it looked cute.
And we said, you know, maybe
we can actually develop a
system that automatically
takes any
data from any database--
you know, all these databases
are hidden down
there in your cellars--
and exposing it to managers
in a way that is going to
facilitate the decision
making.
And what we did, we developed
a mock-up of that system.
And we went around and we
interviewed 15 customers and
we asked them what they thought
about the idea.
It was a small company.
It was privately-owned.
I had no resources.
This was early days.
VC industry in Israel
was just nascent.
They weren't really investing.
There were no other software
companies around doing
development work, not
even selling their
products outside of Israel.
So I had to verify that what I'm
doing is really valuable.
So we went and we interviewed
these 15 customers, and we got
amazing feedback.
We found out that there are
other vendors in the field.
We found out that customers
really have very specific
requirements about what they
want such a system to do.
And we also found out that
customers can really drive
competitive value, if the system
was to work, according
to their needs.
And these needs were
very complex.
So we started development.
We were lucky.
One day, after a couple of
months, we got a phone call
from one of these customers
that we interviewed, an
insurance company, and they told
us, you know, we looked
at what you are offering us and
we think this system can
bring strategic value to us,
and we want to buy it.
We only had a mock-up.
We didn't really
have a system.
But luckily, they were a company
who was just starting
operations-- it's an
insurance company--
so they didn't really
have a [INAUDIBLE].
So we said, you know what?
We build a system according to
your specifications, and you'd
be our first customer.
You have to understand.
This is it.
This is what we can offer.
And they were willing
to gamble on us.
They thought that if we build
a system according to their
needs, they're going to have
such a tremendous value, that
it's worth the risk that
they are taking.
The only caveat was that they
said that they would pay only
after a year of operation.
[INAUDIBLE].
So I had to make a very tough
decision of deciding to
develop and invest in the
development of a product out
of my own funds.
It's not something that I
grew up thinking I would
ever have to do.
And I really had to kind of put
my hand in my pocket and
pay for the people
to do their work.
The team was wonderful, and they
really collaborated well.
They did consulting in the
morning, and development in
the afternoon, and then we
worked nights and days and
weekends, et cetera.
And we were successful.
We were so successful that the
guy who decided on the product
to buy the product for this
insurance company called us
six months later to
say thank you.
He was just promoted
to vice president.
Because he was an actuary, and
he did such a great job in
being an actuary for
this insurance
company, that he was promoted.
Eventually, two years later,
he also became the CEO.
So you can see that when you use
the system right, if you
do a good job with BI, it
could change the whole
strategy of the organization.
It can make the difference
between a successful and
unsuccessful organization.
And I was extremely, extremely
proud of that.
But here I was with customer,
so I went around--
we sold the system to another
customer and to another
customer and what we found out
this would be that there was a
technical problem that people
had when they developed a
system like that.
The way the other systems in the
market worked was that in
order to provide immediate
response time to all these
type of queries that people may
ask, they precalculated
overnight all the potential
queries that
anybody would ask.
Google would know a
little about that.
So you know something about
precalculation.
And that was great.
But when you come to an
organization that has dozens
of millions of records, and you
have to precalculate, you
may get to hundreds [INAUDIBLE]
of precalculations
and it would be a very tedious
and time consuming process.
So one day we had
a breakthrough.
We thought about it and said,
well, how many decision-makers
are there maybe in an
organization, a thousand?
How many questions each one
maybe asking over a year,
what, a hundred?
So what are we talking about?
100,000 questions.
Why do we precalculate?
A hundred million?
The big question is, so how do
you know which questions to
precalculate?
So what we developed was the
first multi-dimensional
engine, which is the technology
we are talking
about, that knew to learn from
experience from the way people
were using the system.
And Google knows about
that, right?
We developed the system based
on the way that people were
using the system, we will decide
what to precalculate
and what not.
So we would, indeed, sometimes
and somebody would come out
with a question out of the blue,
it would take longer.
But all the rest of the
questions were answered
immediately, and that one
question that took a long time
would also be answered
very quickly the
next time it was asked.
So we found a way to create a
multi-dimensional engine that
was fitted the way that people
were using the system.
Which is very much like what
we are all doing today,
contextual, right?
So we developed what we might
call a contextual,
multi-dimensional engine.
So it was a great
breakthrough.
It simplified development.
It simplified the lifecycle
of the system.
And that was a wonderful
system.
DANIELA RAIJMAN-AHARONOV: Is
that the technology that was
eventually sold to Microsoft?
RONY ROSS: Exactly.
The story about it is funny.
Because what happened is that
first of all, I went and I
tried to raise capital
for the [INAUDIBLE].
I had three customers, a great
technology, beautiful user
interface, obviously a great
story in a fledgling market.
It was a growing market.
You could see the
people were very
interested in this system.
And why I wanted the funds?
I really wanted the funds
so as to start
marketing the product.
And what a wonderful
business plan.
And I laid it all down and there
were about eight VCs,
just new visitors in Israel
that were just starting an
operation and I went and visited
every single one of
them, gave them a page, gave
them customer testimonials and
everything, and they looked at
me and they said, this lady,
she's not from X200.
The Israel-- the military
intelligence unit where most
of the geeks to date
still come from.
She's not an ex-pilot, so she
doesn't really fit the model
of a startup entrepreneur
that we can think of.
And they didn't invest.
So--
MICHAL SEGALOV: Do you think
this has changed?
Or you succeeding has
changed that plan?
RONY ROSS: Oh, absolutely!
Absolutely changed, but it also
changed everything for
me, because eventually what I
did, was I actually adopted
some business principles that
made a huge difference to the
way that I ran my business.
And it really brought me to a
situation where my product was
extremely competitive.
Because I actually
found myself with
my back now to wall.
I had no money to fund
international marketing and
sales, and I had to think what
I'm going to do with my
product, outside of the
Israeli-- which was great.
It's a great market, it's a
great, better site, but it's a
relatively limited market.
So I decided I'm going to give
myself up for publishing with
a big flair.
You know, there are database
vendors, there are ERP vendors
out there, you know, some of
them, they had to plug it.
So how do I prepare myself
for something like that.
I'll bill myself as a
company that they
will think is a valuable--
with a product that they
will appreciate.
And the way that I did it is
I decided I want to try to
assemble as many different
customers into the product as
possible, and I will adopt all
of the requirements these
customers are asking from me.
It was a very unusual way
of doing business.
It wasn't really the best
practice that everybody would
tell you about developing
a product.
But as a result of these two
decisions, we actually came to
have product that was extremely
powerful, and
eventually after two years, we
had a roster of 65 customers.
Everything from the largest
settle-up company to two of
the larger banks, and a couple
of insurance companies, and a
pharmaceutical, and
an education
institute, and whatever--
everything you could think of.
And eventually, when we got to
meet with Microsoft, it took
them exactly a 3-hour demo, and
after the demo, they took
us out to lunch.
And over lunch, the guy who sat
next to me turned to me
and said, you know, you have
great technology, and a very
attractive product, and
it seems like you
have a great team.
We at Microsoft, we have great
marketing and sales
capabilities.
Do you think you'd
ever consider
selling us your company?
DANIELA RAIJMAN-AHARONOV:Wow.
[LAUGHTER]
RONY ROSS:Just like that.
Out of the blue.
And believe me, it was
out of the blue.
Because the last thing I
imagined was that I would get
a proposal from Microsoft,
right?
Microsoft!
MICHAL SEGALOV: Partner?
RONY ROSS: It's not a partner.
I thought maybe they're asking
to develop something,
something like that.
I thought of myself more
of a small outfit.
And I was scared, you know,
because we were actually
working out in a garage.
It was a small apartment,
an underground
apartment type of thing.
And I thought they will come,
they will see all my
development team sitting
in one room.
What will they think?
And you know what?
They came.
And they actually liked it,
because they realize that if
you have all of your developers
sitting together in
one room, they really
collaborate with each other.
They know how to work
together as a team.
And eventually, this team
continued to work for
Microsoft for 10 years,
as a team.
Leading the whole BI industry
within Microsoft.
Which was a great value
to Microsoft.
Obviously not a great value for
me, because whatever money
Microsoft paid, I haven't had
any investors to share with.
DANIELA RAIJMAN-AHARONOV:
You were lucky that the
VCs turned you down.
MICHAL SEGALOV: So this scale of
approach that you took, do
you think that the fact that you
decided to focus on more
diversity in terms of customers
was the key aspect,
or was it the great team that
you had and the collaboration
that they had between them?
RONY ROSS: It was everything
together.
You can't do everything--
you have to have the team, and
actually it was a great team,
a really great team.
You had to have the know-how to
what you want to develop,
and that's what my customers
really told me.
It was amazing.
I thought the customers
were crazy.
They would ask all sorts of--
why do you want to do that?
And it was really necessary.
So we actually learned
from our customers.
And today, this is what
we try to do.
We try to learn from our
customers and it always helped
us to develop better product.
And the reason that we are able
to do that, by the way,
you know, here we are
sitting in Israel--
Israel is small.
All their customers, every
industry, every type of
organization is within
a one-hour
drive from your office.
And everything is very open
and very accessible.
So here we can interview
three customers a day.
And this is what makes such
a huge difference.
MICHAL SEGALOV: So it sounds
like the customers are really
key throughout your career, but
how do you scale this up?
I mean, I'm sure that you have
many more customers now, so
starting with 50 must be easy
for doing this now.
RONY ROSS: No, obviously we
don't do that anymore.
No, we do that in the respect
of in the development.
We have key customers that we
integrate into the process.
And we interview them
extensively, and they're part
of our beta program,
and we learn a
lot from their feedback.
We continue to listen
to our customers.
Customers are extremely
key to us.
DANIELA RAIJMAN-AHARONOV: So
going back to maybe a little
bit outside of Panorama
Software.
RONY ROSS: OK.
DANIELA RAIJMAN-AHARONOV: So did
you always know they want
to found your own company
and what was your prior
experience?
How did it prepare you
to being an actual
founder of a company?
RONY ROSS: So it's
interesting.
I didn't really think I was
going to be an owner of a
company, first when I started.
I must admit, as a young woman
I had not very concrete ideas
of career and where
I'm going there.
I was much less determined.
You would think, based on--
because I was sad.
The term entrepreneurship
didn't really exist.
And the funny thing is that
the first time I heard the
word "exit," was when I
overheard somebody say, "Rony
Ross, who's this Rony Ross?
She had an exit." I had what?
That's what I mean.
This is how nascent
this thing.
This was the first deal that
anybody ever sold technology
outside of Israel in the
software industry.
And obviously, not really the
first time we did use somebody
like Microsoft, which
was very important.
The most important partner
part potential
possible at the time.
So I didn't have this concept
very, very clearly, but once I
got there, I knew this is
what I should be doing.
I knew this is what
I'm good at.
And even though I spent
sleepless nights worrying
whether I'm going to meet
payroll or not.
And even though I worked myself
to the bone, and I felt
like I'm bleeding from climbing
walls sometimes, I
just kept on doing it and
eventually, for me, it worked.
It wasn't very easy, really.
MICHAL SEGALOV: And so, going
back to Panorama, recently
your headquarters moved
to Toronto.
RONY ROSS: Yes.
MICHAL SEGALOV: How would you
say that affected the company,
and what you think about
startups in Israel versus
North America, Silicon
Valley, et cetera?
RONY ROSS:So, I think 2003,
indeed, Panorama specialized
really itself as a developer.
First developing the first
generation, then second
generation, but all our sales
were done through partners,
big partnerships outside the
first generation with
Microsoft, the second generation
with Kronos, we
never really ventured
outside of Israel.
Then in 2003, we could see that
the Business Intelligence
market is booming, and what we
have is a really competitive
product, so we raised capital
and we opened up our
headquarters in Toronto.
I, myself, relocated to Canada
with my husband, together with
two other people from Panorama
to open up this facility, and
it made a huge difference.
You think that you understand
the mentality of people in The
States or in Canada, who are
your main customers, but you
don't really understand it.
Both from experience, but also
from actually going--
being on different sides
of the ocean.
All of a sudden, when you found
yourself sitting in
Toronto and the guys in Israel,
all of a sudden on the
other side and other people in
UK and other people in the US,
all of a sudden, you understand
what it takes in
order for a company to
really become global.
What it takes in order to
prepare your team, to support
not only your customers, but
yourself, each other.
Sharing the know-how.
Understanding how to
support each other.
How to engage people.
How to help them
be productive.
It made a huge difference
to us.
And I can only say that if you
ever wanted a startup to work,
to bring yourself into a larger
company, you have to
work for at least a few
years internationally.
That's my belief.
I also recommend for everybody
to go back.
The weather is better, the
social life is wonderful, and
besides, you know, me, if I get
up in the morning and I
don't see big headlines in the
newspaper, or something that
makes you, "Oh, oh, oh, my life
is in danger!" I don't
know how I'm going to
go through the day.
Just a simple, quiet newspaper
like in Toronto, you'll never
do it to me.
DANIELA RAIJMAN-AHARONOV: You
like living on the edge.
RONY ROSS: Exactly.
MICHAL SEGALOV: Do you think
this is changing?
I mean, on one hand, there
is more technology
now available, right?
There is a video conferencing
that's really good, Google
Hangouts, and so on, but then
on the other hand, there's a
lot more competition.
So how do you think
these two play?
RONY ROSS: Well, first of all,
it's true. that there was a
lot of competition.
But you see, if you have
creative minds, you always get
to do something which nobody
ever though of.
For example, this third
generation, what we call BI
3.0, this concept of taking
the social, and the
contextual, and the suggestive
into the BI system, the fact
is that we thought about it
and other company was just
taking it on.
I was scrambling, trying to
say me too, me too kind of
stuff, and they went there.
So there was a low limit to
creativity and there's no
limit to the way technology
reshapes itself and reshapes
the way that you're working.
I can still remember a time
before the internet, and that
was there, and there was not
always internet around, and
now there is internet around, so
we change everything and I
remember a time where there
was no iPhone around.
So and now we change everything
that we do.
And in five years, people will
say, "Wow, we had BI that
wasn't collaborative?
How could we work?" That's
what they mean.
And you don't know what is
going to be the next wave
that's going to change the
way that we all will even
interact, in five
years from now.
MICHAL SEGALOV: So how do
you get a hint for that.
You identify something
that will--
RONY ROSS: Yes, exactly.
MICHAL SEGALOV: How
do you do that?
How do you get that hint?
RONY ROSS: I don't know.
I can't explain it, really.
It's having people--
we try.
We kept on.
Almost every year, we have
strategic sessions, where all
our management team, and our
creative team, and our design
team, sit together--
it's kind of a retreat
version--
and we think about
what's next.
What is changing?
How is the world changing
and how does it
affect what we are doing?
What is the possibility of it
to affect what we are doing?
Because here, the first
generation Panorama, the big
thing was Windows.
The second generation, by the
way, was the internet.
We developed an engine that
enabled internet deployment
for us of BI.
The first one in the Microsoft
environment.
And now, this thing about
enabling Panorama and blending
social and interaction.
So it's something that
the company either
has or doesn't have.
And you know what?
In the process, we also made
gambles that didn't work.
There's no guarantee.
You try things, and sometimes
you think you're onto the very
next big thing, and it doesn't
always work that way.
And it hurts, and you spend a
lot of money, but it doesn't
necessarily work.
MICHAL SEGALOV: But knowing
when to stop is another
important skill.
RONY ROSS: Yeah, you have to
know when to stop, and when to
change, and when to adopt.
It's very complex in
the fast lane.
MICHAL SEGALOV: How do you
choose which activities or
what changes to be
involved in?
You must get a lot of offers
from-- either from other
companies or industries?
RONY ROSS: Yes, I get a lot.
I try to limit myself
basically to areas
that I fit good with.
That I can feel that
I can contribute.
Just being a dumb investor
has no value.
Not to me and not
to the other.
People think that it's enough
to raise money, and bringing
any type of money is helpful.
It is, in a sense, but the truth
is, if you bring money
that can also have strategic
value and we get, for example,
strategic value from our
investors, we get strategic
value from our board members.
If you get that, you're in
a much better position.
MICHAL SEGALOV: So your advice
to someone starting a startup
would be to choose the
right investor?
RONY ROSS: Yes, absolutely.
If they can choose investors
who are useful to them, it
will make a huge difference.
Eventually, as an entrepreneur,
it is a very
lonely road.
There are so many difficulties,
and so many
hardships, and so many issues.
If you have somebody that you
can really, truly help--
who can really, truly help
you, it's priceless.
MICHAL SEGALOV: Have you had
mentors or people that were
with you along the way?
RONY ROSS: As I said, when I
started, there were very few
people who were doing what
I was doing intuitively.
What influenced me a lot,
was, as I told you,
I started in Scitex.
I don't know if you know that it
was started by [INAUDIBLE]
was practically one of
the really first
entrepreneurs anywhere.
And it was always a model of
me, what Scitex was doing.
And actually, from Scitex, I
think, probably over 50 maybe
even over 100 similar startups,
some of them
successful, some of them less
so great, but was formed,
based on the experience
that we, as
people, experienced there.
So he was one hero
that I followed.
But my mentor in my early career
was actually my father,
[INAUDIBLE], was a very,
very wise man.
I was lucky to have a person
like him that many people
valued as a consultant.
As a mentor, I had him naturally
and I didn't have to
pay for his time.
And today, my brother is
actually-- you know, my father
passed away four years ago,
and my brother is actually
stepping up, in a way, and
becoming kind of my alter ego,
trying to help me resolve
issues that I face.
DANIELA RAIJMAN-AHARONOV: So I
think that this story that
you've told us is really
amazing, and the Women
Techmakers series also features
really great women
leaders, but it's not a secret
that there aren't as many
women leaders as there
should be.
So what do you think is the
reason that we don't see more
women in top positions?
RONY ROSS: It stems maybe
because of the should be.
The should be is a relatively
new thing.
Don't forget that until, I don't
know, 40, 50 years ago,
women did not necessarily--
were not really compelled, did
not feel that they have to
become part of the workforce, or
take care of the social and
economic future of
their families.
Marriages were a long-term
affair.
The arrangement was that a woman
would look after the
house, which at that time,
was very time-consuming.
No dishwashers, no washing
machine, et cetera.
And the men were out there
bringing in the money.
These things change.
First of all, technology
enabled the change.
It made life, home-keeping much
easier, simple, it's not
a full-time job.
And we changed also the social
and economical way that we
look at the world.
But by deciding that we want an
option not to stay married,
or not to get married or marry
late or do what we want.
We wanted to control
our own destiny.
And it meant that both sides are
no longer committed to a
very long-term relationship.
And as a result, it means that
at least 50 if not more--
I don't have statistics, but I
think it's probably over 60--
60 percent of the women will
find themselves as the main
providers of the family,
themselves and their children
at the major portion
of their life.
Maybe all their life, maybe
a major portion.
Why?
Because either they will not
get married, or they'll get
divorced, or their spouses will
not be able to support
them, and the work conditions
change for them.
I don't want to get into that.
Anyway, then we find that the
responsibility for the family
is on their shoulders.
And that means where they're
going to live, which
neighborhood, what type of
house, what kind of car will
take the children to school,
what kind of vacation they can
afford to himself, what kind
of education, what kind of
after-school activities, what
type of universities they can
send their children to.
Whew!
This is a huge responsibility.
And we don't have it in
our genes, right?
All these years, it wasn't
our responsibility.
So we never really understood
ourselves as the breadwinner
of my family.
I am the breadwinner
And I have to make sure that
I act accordingly.
I don't think we had
it in ourselves so
much over the years.
And it's something
that changes.
You can also see when you
say to women, money.
It's not me.
Oh, yes it is you.
Money is you.
So you have to step up and say,
I want this career, I
want this position, I want the
money, I want the option, I
want this, I want the perks.
All these things that
we, kind of--
it wasn't in us so much.
We have to change this attitude
to fix the new
conditions that we are in.
There is no prince on a white
horse who is going to come out
and rescue you, damsel
in distress,
and make life simple.
MICHAL SEGALOV: Were you
always thinking that?
Or is that something
that evolved?
RONY ROSS: I did.
I actually felt myself--
I was very self-reliant from
very early on, and
I became more so.
But all of a sudden, I started
looking around, trying to
understand why is it that I
feel this and other people
don't get there as much.
And I realized, that we have
an issue with money.
We have an issue with
identifying ourselves with our
social and economic future.
We have always that thing
that maybe somebody will
take care of it.
It's not.
MICHAL SEGALOV: How
important is
risk-taking with that approach?
RONY ROSS: It's very
important.
And it's part of that, because
part of the thing about
fortune favors the bold,
you have to take
risks in order to succeed.
And you have to risk the fact
that you're going to fail.
It's not easy, but I don't want
to see the world changing
and all of these lower echelons,
the social economic
echelons full of matriarchal
families.
And actually, you can see
that in many respects.
If you look carefully at
the data, you will find
out that it's true.
So we actually have to build
ourselves better to build a
career, to stand up
for a career--
and it's not just a career, not
what I'd like to do, it's
what makes money.
It's what makes you successful
financially.
It's very important.
Because it's not just for
me, it's for my kids.
It's for my family.
DANIELA RAIJMAN-AHARONOV: So
we're almost out of time, but
there's one thing I really want
to ask you and that's out
of everything that you've told
us, and what you haven't had
time to tell us yet, what are
you the most proud of?
RONY ROSS: You know, I said at
the beginning that one of the
things that I always had in my
mind was to be able to bring
strategic value to the
organization through the IT.
And the thing that always makes
a difference to me is
when I meet him.
Another CEO, a chairman of
another company, and they will
tell you, you know, there isn't
a single decision in our
organization that's not taken
through your Panorama system.
This really makes it for me.
Knowing that my customer's
life, financially and
strategically, is made
better, through
the use of my software.
It's an amazing feeling.
MICHAL SEGALOV: Indeed.
DANIELA RAIJMAN-AHARONOV: So
Rony, thank you so much for
speaking to us and telling
us your story.
Thank you, Michal.
And thank you all for tuning
into the first episode of
Women Techmakers in Israel.
We will have some more really
exciting episodes coming up,
and, of course, we have the
Women Techmakers episodes
already online from
the United States.
So a good day to all
of you and goodbye!
MICHAL SEGALOV: Goodbye!
Thank you, Rony.
RONY ROSS: OK.
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]